three two one
good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing day so far
i know we are because if you're watching
on youtube you obviously are seeing the
major changes that have happened to our
major florida studio we got new my dad
sickening wallpaper it is so gorgeous
this is the florida vibe this is what
we've been waiting for this is when we
said like my studio is going to be like
so fun and cool and unique and special
like not like other studios this is what
it was and it is that studio i'm
obsessed with sitting here i'm obsessed
with like looking at us in the camera
like i'm just obsessed with the whole
look and so i just want to say like if
you don't have anything nice to say
i'm not listening the thing is i don't
even think you have to say that because
i cannot see someone who watches this
show who obviously if you watch a show
like you have taste you have style
you're funny you're interesting you're
beautiful stunning and smart so if
that's you like you couldn't possibly
conjure up a negative thought to think
about this wallpaper because it's so
beyond sickening it's also like
[Laughter]
it's on brand toasty it's on brand
florida like literally line country
safari if you know you know if you know
you know but we're also like doing
something new for us which i love you
know i've been advocating for like a
little bit of a rebrand on toast
not anything major i love our toasty
vibes but this is a refresh and i love
that for us i love it too i feel i feel
like every episode we've done thus far
like
was amazing but something was missing
and then it realized like flamingo was
missing it was the flamingos that we're
missing now we have to come up with
names for the flamingos obviously but i
think we should just let that happen
naturally over time i know that this one
is jackie flamingo
oh i know that um this one is claudio
claudio that's good claudio yeah um so
we're feeling good in our new studio
second episode of the week lots happened
yesterday we have a brand new um vlog up
on the patreon
for those who are wondering like what
the [ __ ] i do here all day i did a day
in the live vlog yesterday was like kind
of a crazy day obviously being working
woman also like you know i had to take
care of kayla there was a gap in her
schedule where like
there was no one to watch kayla and of
course number one auntie showed up and
showed out um and i also dive into like
a little bit of my complicated
relationship with michaela these days
because um she's just like
like hating me
and it's almost like the more love i
give her the more love she taketh away
from me and it's been really challenging
as an auntie and i think other aunties
can probably relate to this issue yes
but as discussed we have different
anti-styles and i think that my style
is what k prefers right now which is
just like meet you where you're at not
gonna like do anything that you don't
wanna do like if you wanna give me a hug
i will accept the hug i'm not going in
for a hug you know it's important to
note that over the last week um more
importantly the last 72 hours um mckayla
has added a bunch of new words to her
vocabulary those words being ben
jack zack and uncle there's not an anti
in sight there's not a claudia in sight
there's not a claude in sight there's
nothing and i i am deep like i'm taking
it personally so what you're saying is
michaela's gaslighting you
i would say it's more of a manipulation
like an emotional torture yeah than a
gaslighting but i would i wouldn't put
it past her is what i'm saying and
that's that's just kind of where we're
at so i talk about that in the vlog um
we had a really fun dinner last night we
did an absolutely
bocce at olivia's house that she set up
which she knows is like my favorite
cuisine of all time and we have hibachi
leftovers for lunch today so today's
gonna be a fabulous day and there's not
a lot so i'm not like offering to share
like there's very little and i think
your husband took home somebody so there
might be some in your fridge he did
i don't think there is
but it was delicious and unless you know
what leave me wanting more i actually
didn't fill up which i thought that i
would and i was like i could go for a
little snack what'd you get i had a
ice pop like not
i don't know what the brand is olivia
made me buy them and i enjoyed it yeah
so and i enjoyed it with your vlog and
it was such a delicious evening bryce
was loving the vlog he saw himself oh my
god at one point in the vlog you hear me
yelling like i'm the dream
and i don't yell at the dogs like that
but let me tell you what they did so
because i didn't even notice you yelling
at the vlog at the dogs i guess that's
just like part of the chaotic nature of
our youtube videos i don't even notice
someone blood-curdlingly screaming in
the background um when i tell you all
the youtube comments all the patreon
comments everyone's like what the [ __ ]
is jackie screaming at i don't even know
what they're talking about okay so i
walked into olivia's pantry which like
doesn't have a door but it's like a
whole room pantry and bryce and
streister diving into theo's huge bag of
food like one of those bags of foods
from cheaper but beethoven from those
for those dogs and you know bruno he's
broudini and he found a way to get in
there and he's showing theo his tricks
and they are diving into the bag and so
at first i was going in there to make a
bottle and so i was like get out get out
and
and then i realized i was like oh no i
need to like be stronger about this
behavior because this is really bad so
then i was like get out kids you
literally tapped into like your strict
mom era i really did and you captured it
i didn't even hear it because i was
obviously so busy like looking at myself
in the camera like what do i look like
what i sound like how's my skin so um
thanks for clearing that up
so that's what they were doing and bruno
is a bad influence because it's
his broodini skills harry bridge harry
and bourdini yeah
literally yeah um so new content up on
the patreon um we're just like kind of
churning out the content while we're
here down in florida so it's a great
vlog camera and i think that's also made
the difference it's so much more fun to
do a vlog on this like i literally like
copied whatever olivia jade had because
like her vlogs are always like clear
um and i got this new camera so it makes
it more fun to vlog we look sickening
and
we're just churning out the content so
it's a great time to become a patreon
member it is if you want more behind the
scenes of what we're doing here every
day you know and wallpaper patreon saw
it first last night you guys they knew
about this if you're a patreon member
like this wallpaper is not a surprise to
you because it was a huge part of our
day getting it installed waiting for it
to be finished like being excited about
it so if you're a patreon member this is
actually old news yeah
sorry
um if you're a patreon member also
great segue i just announced yesterday
the final i think it's 11 or 12 dates
for the not like other girls tour my
tour that i started at the beginning of
the year is finishing out uh
september august september october and
november of this year i added seattle uh
portland nashville charlotte durham um
lots of good places so patreon pre-sale
starts tomorrow if you're hoping to
secure a meet and greet they usually fly
in the patreon pre-sale which
sucks for everyone else so it's a great
time to become a patreon member for that
reason and then if you are not in the
the space to become a patreon member
which is also fine um general on sale
starts for everyone for those tickets on
fridays so just like prepare yourselves
you have until either tomorrow or friday
to get sickening tickets to the last 11
shows historic shows of the not like
other girls tour
and that's on being a comedian so yeah
great and speaking of content new
episode of the redheads is recording
tonight dropping on thursday i feel like
a lot of people are becoming redheads
recently i was looking at the numbers
and the thing about redheads episodes is
like they are evergreen so i could go
back to one from two years ago and
people are listening to it and it's
growing and climbing and like all of our
numbers are really growing across all
episodes can i ask you a question
which book or which episode that you
guys have done has the most listens like
by far our first one just because it's
had the most amount of time to occur of
course of course listens but
that's a top one that so that was the
husband's secret which is also just a
really good and popular book by leanne
moriarty who's a really good and popular
author except for her last book like no
offense no against leanne no offense the
end yeah no sense miss moriarty but you
know it's she's not perfect stranger
she's big little guys like she's fine
yeah uh that was really popular your
episode is obviously really popular girl
with no job we recap claudia's book and
asked her some personal questions and
before we were stranger which is that uh
renee carlino which kind of just like
set off like this renee carlino stanhood
in motion for so many of our yeah me too
i had a bunch of renee carly nobody for
you for snitch and that was really like
our first runaway hit i would say you'd
love to see that but i do think that
this week's episode is another one
that's like that and the author it's her
first book and i was looking at her
instagram and she looks like so young
she has an illustrious career ahead of
her because this book is that book it's
called a flicker in the dark you know
that's also the same thing with the book
that's going viral now every summer
after it's her first book she's like so
young and cute on her instagram she's
like cannot believe her book is blowing
up it's so cute to see i'm so happy for
her i think it's the same thing for this
author like it's a new york times
bestseller and you just love to see
quality
winning winning yeah you really do
because a lot of times quality doesn't
win and a lot of times like non-quality
wins remember you know what i mean yeah
i mean i don't want to single out like
one particular author but
like that's what it is like everyone's
obsessed like oh man this author has a
new book and it's literally not good
none of them have been good that i've
read interesting i'm not gonna say it's
not me it's me because someone puts
their heart and soul into that book and
other people like books and by the way
books are more personal than comedy more
personal than food i agree and so that's
something i'm like struggling with with
posting my reviews on um my instagram
and part of the reason why i went
private on tick tock is like not tick
tock i would never private
private on goodreads it's like sometimes
i [ __ ] hate a book and like i want to
give an honest opinion but i have to say
it nicely because like i posted a little
while ago about the first ellen
hildebrandt golden girl and like then
she followed me which is amazing and i
thank god i have nothing negative to say
about her books thus far but what if i
think one's a stinker you know yeah
that's it
like people work years on books so i
just have to not for me
yeah not my favorite yeah
yeah that's why i mean in addition to
like other reasons we don't like have
seek out having authors on the redheads
like the authors of the book and i'm
sure for some
like we could keep dreaming but for
others like we could probably make it
happen but we want to be able to have an
honest combo it does take it like it
makes you feel like the princess is
always like your artist integrity yeah
and we are artists and you're integral
beyond
so um
congratulations on the new episode of
the redheads that's coming out that
hasn't happened yet i'm excited for it
thank you very much um
and i feel like i don't really have that
much else to catch up on because i was
just like busy vlogging editing
everything is in the blog everything
that i would say and i don't want to
spoil it spoiler alert no i'm literally
becoming like am i
casey neistat like with my camera and my
blogs i think that you are i think that
i am too are you gonna do another vlog
what what would be your next subject
honestly i feel like i've been so like
at the forefront of the patreon like i
think you need to pick up the camera
like i think people are like oh this is
fun jack is the interesting one who just
moved and had a baby can we hear from
her oh sure true when i have a spare
second of my day i'm going to vlog i
have so many things like on deck that
i've been meaning to do but your next
subject was actually meant to be zak
shapiro yes yes um annie leibowitz is
taking the focus away from herself and
on to one of her constituents um and
that would be zak shapiro people are
just like kind of breakout star from
this trip down to florida olivia's
husband zack shapiro yeah so claudia was
gonna do a day in the life of zak
shapiro i know but like he's really busy
and like so i get ready in olivia's
bathroom and olivia's house has like two
working spaces one of them is in her
bedroom and one of them is like an
official office and zach does the one in
the bedroom so when i go like in and out
of the bedroom at nine just to like you
know get a coffee or go do my makeup or
my hair like i feel like such a [ __ ]
intruder like imagine if you were with
your vlog on the camera right and he's
like talking about i don't know like
confidential information at his job
and they were like say out of the beach
and he's so nice he would never say
anything but i'm like yeah i am doing
everything in my power not to become
like a burden in olivia's home you know
because you have been there for 10 days
and i keep saying to her i'm like
just tell me when i'm being annoying
like i can always go stay at jackie's
like you guys have a lot going on like
with michaela so i tried to like clean
as much as possible i was like folding
out the towels yesterday like i just
want to make life easier and i know that
ben staying at someone's house like
automatically makes it more difficult
because he'll cook and leave the dishes
like and he's not like intentionally
rude it's subconscious oh my wife will
do it you know like he's so um
just not thoughtful in that way he's
thoughtful in a million other ways so
i'm just trying to make up for my
presence and ben's presence as well and
not become this like oh we can't wait
for this [ __ ] to leave i want them to
be like oh why is the house so messy oh
claudia left you know she was so good at
picking up after everyone yeah well you
are always welcome here thank you i've
actually been thinking about things that
i'm gonna get that are going to really
make your stay whenever that elements
elevate your stay like i know the
shampoo that you like oh wow you know
stuff like that that shampoo is
expensive i know i actually didn't buy
it because they only had the huge sizes
and i was about to spend so much money
on shampoo i'm like girl get a grip get
garnier well can i tell you i'm actually
up until my function of beauty i've
really been struggling with um dandruff
every couple of years i like get itchy
scalp i'm like oh dandruff you use head
and shoulders once and it goes away yeah
and olivia's guest bathroom has head and
shoulders so it's actually been really
timely for me
to be using head and shoulders and i
have no complaints she has a great
selection she doesn't happens to have
the same face wash that i use in the
shower i don't need to spend like so
much money on chips no like you
definitely should um
and i feel like it could be a write-off
you know oh that's so true because this
is like but i also realized last night
when i was shopping for shampoo that the
brand that we like has a scalp shampoo
and it's a brand that we like we're not
keeping it's called milbon and we buy it
directly from our hair stylist and it's
like so expensive and it's impossible to
get online i was googling it last night
like the first research results were
from ebay no i have like a really janky
website i'll send it to you i saw
shampoo zone is also a website but they
didn't have the size that i want they
only have the jugs and these are so
expensive i have like a really really
scary website and the box shows up like
duct taped together with like really
it's it's so janky but they offer
multiple sizes and so far the product
has been good because the reason why we
can't find it online is it's a it's a
type of brand of shampoo that you're
only supposed to sell via a salon they
don't sell direct to consumer big
mistake big mistakes so i found some
like janky salon website i don't know
where the salon is based but the [ __ ]
comes i swear i order it i turn around
it's there it's crazy okay give me the
link yeah i will um so thank you for the
effort you're putting into making my own
sweet a premium experience yeah i love
that
okay so i guess without further ado i
mean by the way we without further ado
because like everyone is going to quake
their bones off
from today's lead-in sponsor like it is
a dream come true
an honor and a privilege to be working
with this particular brand for this
particular product so i'm more than
happy to dive in and what's so funny is
there's another sponsor today that is
like one of my parts something i eat
every single day you know what okay
so we could do them together together
because it's our favorite food groups
but i just also want to address the lack
of dew
yeah theo's not here today um because
yesterday he made my legs look that when
he was sitting on my lap and that's just
like a personal boundary i will not
allow for yeah i couldn't and i've been
watching usually i never watch our
episodes but in florida like i've been
really enjoying watching our episodes
once we're done with them because
i don't know it's like fun and fresh and
i could not get myself to watch them
yesterday my [ __ ] knees looked
first of all i looked 87 with like my
wrinkling like it was althea's fault
we all know it's my fault but i'm i'm
scapegoating theo no that is why i
switched it up today and i wore like a
tracksuit that way i don't have to worry
about my legs it's also so cold in here
our legs like turn purple and they just
look really grandma
it's not cute yeah no for further notice
like i will not be showing my legs on
this particular set yeah i'm going back
to my merch zone
i i'm with you i'm feeling really great
today this is peloton adidas collab and
creamsicle sickening and i'm just like
so comfortable and it really goes with
the new wallpaper it really does i was
worried it's going to be too chaotic but
i think it's just the right amount of
chaos perfection so now without further
ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode believe it or not is
brought to you i can't believe i'm about
to say this
by mcdonald's
here at the morning toast it is
absolutely no secret that we are
obsessed with mcdonald's after a day of
recording the show or running around
doing errands is there anything better
than a mcdonald's fountain diet coke a
large crispy french fry and their iconic
chicken sandwich here's the important
question what is the best mcdonald's
crispy chicken sandwich is it the
standard one the spicy one the deluxe
one here's the answer jackie
all of the above i think mcdonald's
chicken sandwiches are more personal
than comedy agreed because i'm
personally like a standard girly and i
know that the way that i eat a chicken
sandwich is not the popular way and i
know that about myself that doesn't make
it any less delicious like i literally
got [ __ ] on like a couple days ago for
putting ketchup on a chicken sandwich
and i can't believe there are other
people who don't do that because the way
that i do it bun ketchup chicken bun
that's it soda fries mcflurry um but
that's just me like maybe you like the
spicy maybe you like the deluxe maybe
you like extra pickles that's on you
because like jackie said chicken
sandwiches from mcdonald's are more
personal than comedy the mcdonald's
crispy chicken sandwich you can order it
ahead on the mcdonald's app and you can
try the sandwich that invented crispy
juicy tender today at participating
mcdonald's you can download the app and
registration is required and this is
just a reminder to you that like the
chicken sandwich is out there waiting to
be eaten and we are the girls here to
remind you that it is time and treat
yourself today you know get out there go
to lunch treat yourself to a chicken
sandwich crispy fries
toasted potato roll a crinkle cut pickle
if you get the spicy crispy chicken
sandwich you get a spicy pepper sauce
like there's so much to be done add this
remove that like it's perfection you
guys and
that's on being elite and also every
episode of the toast like you come away
with at least one takeaway sometimes 12.
if today we give you nothing else let us
inspire you for lunch for lunch yeah i
love that um and today's second sponsor
is a personal favorite of jackie's as
well it is go macro
so for the fight against against cancer
a mother and daughter took their love to
the kitchen and go macro was born now
they are spreading the power of a
balanced plant-based lifestyle across
the country with go macro they're
available in 16 mouth-watering flavors
macro bars are packed with 100
plant-based ingredients to fuel your
body and mind macro bars are made from
simple high-quality ingredients and are
certified organic vegan gluten-free
kosher non-gmo and soy free before you
dive into your obsession i think it's
important to know jackie like has had
the biggest box of um macro bars in our
studio and for the longest time i
thought it was called gomcrow
and that's just like on not being able
to read
so
we have go macro bars in our studio but
they i have them at my house too they're
the only bars that i eat that like
actually make me not hungry anymore like
usually a bar is just like a placeholder
until you can get your meal but like for
me if i'm having it like it's my
breakfast they're so tasty and delicious
but just like filling and as stated made
with things that are actually good for
you i started eating go macro bars you
won't know how i was introduced to them
like three years ago in a good american
press box it was like the best press box
that you talked about all the time
because it's a gift that keeps on giving
they sent like this amazing duffel they
said go macro bars i had never heard of
them before and i was like i like a bar
let me try it there are such good
flavors there are so many flavors you
never get sick of the ones i was eating
like the chocolate peanut butter ones in
the studio literally every single day
after the toast and they are my bars of
choice and i'm so
glad to be able to share the gospel
they're made from simple high quality
ingredients and they are packed with
organic gluten-free deliciousness and
just when you thought it couldn't get
any better a percentage of the proceeds
from their august sales of the double
chocolate and peanut butter chips will
be donated to the sheldrick wildlife
trust it's a pioneering conserve
conservation organization dedicated to
the protection of wildlife and
preservation of the habitats in east
africa they are best known for their
work to protect the elephants so not
only does go macro bar make delicious
bars but they're also making a positive
change towards a better planet you can
join go macro in supporting important
conservation work and get your hands on
these two new flavors by going to
gomacro.com and using the promo code
toast for 30 off plus free shipping on
orders of over 50
so again that's code yeah say that again
for me yeah i just ordered something
from new house go macro.com
g-o-m-a-c-r-o dot com the promo code is
chosen for 30 off plus free shipping on
all orders over 50
so gorgeous
check that out will do
oh now it's my turn
so we have some great stories today i
think i hope
yes actually we do okay our first story
some crazy drama winona and ashley judd
were left out of their mom naomi's will
so i'm not sure if we spoke about this
on the toast about her passing about her
passing i don't think we did um naomi
judd passed away um she died by suicide
a few months ago and her will has
emerged and her only two daughters
winona judd and ashley judd who are also
famous have been left out of her last
will and testament page six can confirm
the late country singer instead
appointed her husband of 33 years larry
strickland as executor of her estate
according to the court documents is
larry the girl's dad
it
feels like no it feels like no two
because
if different last name first of all
right and if
he was their dad then it wouldn't be
such a big deal because
eventually like it would be passed on to
them you know yeah and they were married
33 years and these girls are older than
33. not that it's always apples to
apples but i just don't think it's their
diet right right right okay so this is
so um like weird wild because not only
is that a crazy thing for a parent to do
but like winona
and
actually naomi oh oh they were the judds
like they were the band they like worked
together
and
this just like
it's so it's so bizarre so the mom is
winona right yeah and then the daughters
are ashley and nate no no the mom is
naomi i'm so sorry i get confused yeah
and the daughters are ashley and winona
and winona and naomi like work together
and sing together and then ashley judd
is just like another famous person wait
who's mom naomi
no the mom is naomi yeah okay the mama's
naomi
and so naomi worked with hill winona oh
in music
so that is definitely weird well
obviously it makes people think like
there was bad blood right yeah but
what's weird like you have to have
really
serious beef with your children to leave
them out of your will correct right like
to to slightly intentionally just like
them in the afternoon and they're your
only children and you're leaving all of
them yeah you're not giving them a piece
of anything yeah and what's weird is
that
after she
passed they were like doing all these
things they went to her tribute and this
and that so it's like did they not know
that they had beef or right no it's just
it's
puzzling puzzling she wrote and signed
the will five years ago
i think she could have changed but if
they did isn't the first thing you would
do run to your lawyer's office yeah
and i'm sure we'll never find out like
what's actually going on because it's so
private and at the end of the day it's
not our business yeah but we can you
know yes
it does feel like an episode of dynasty
you know like yeah this is really like
yeah it feels like an uh tv show
especially because they're all famous
right famous
[Music]
and i also read an article this morning
that like winona's pissed obviously
because she thinks she had a lot to do
with like her mom's success because they
did work together together well i can't
lie the reason why i get so confused
between all the different names is
because the judd in my opinion who i
whose name i've heard the most is winona
judd so i would have assumed that's the
mom i feel like the judge i've heard the
most is ashley judd
i feel like they're both the daughters
right and they're both the daughters
right because she's an actress
show me pictures i know winona judd you
know red hair like i i'm familiar i
don't think i'm familiar with ashley
judd i don't know if you would recognize
her of course queen yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's been in everything
and that's the mom i've never seen naomi
judd honestly like so i wonder
i wonder if her will is substantial
you mean her state
yes thank you i'm sure i'm sure it is
too
damn that's gotta that's gotta hurt you
know yeah to be slighted even you know
after someone passes
that's tough stuff i'm wishing i'm the
best and um
things like this you know whales like
they can't be
appealed you know you i mean you could
challenge it but this article she like
says that she signed it under you know
sound mind memory and understanding and
not under any restraint or in any
respect and competent to make a lost
will and testament that's crazy i feel
like the only person who would know why
is the lawyer but you can't talk or the
husband right right right and i wonder
if they're on speaking terms
no it's it's giving dynasty it's getting
filthy rich like
dramatic soap opera because this [ __ ]
like doesn't really happen in real life
you know yeah or it's like sometimes i
feel like parents do this to like teach
their kids listen we're like they're
gonna donate it all to charity but like
these kids are grown they all like work
together so they lessons were learned
all right right no this is like i think
bill gates what gives his daughter like
five dollars a month yeah just so that
she's not
and like i titled i just like i do
appreciate like the
the um
the
the reasoning why a lot of people do
that like i think you know to work
nothing no days in your life and then
turn 18 and get a billion dollars like
ain't right i just definitely feel like
there's a middle ground you know like
like you don't buy them on a plane for
sure but like five dollars like yeah
what about like 100 you know yeah plus
the girls already successful it's not
like they haven't
earned or worked right right that's
crazy and now everyone's just talking
about them like wondering what went
wrong yeah i'm curious but we we truly
will never know
unless there's a book you know by larry
the husband yeah i mean if he ever
chooses to write one i'd probably like
have moved on by then but just like
remind me whenever it comes out one of
these articles will pick it up like
here's why yeah yeah they're good at
that
thanks guys
are you ready for our next story yeah
more crazy news travis scott lands a las
vegas residency nearly one year after
the astroworld tragedy not even one year
it's august just began and asher was in
november so it's wait what yep he is
headed back to the big stage nearly one
year after 10 people died of compression
asphyxia during his astral world
festival in 2021 zuke nightclub in las
vegas announced on monday the rapper
would be playing seven shows at their
venue starting next month
road to utopia will be a quote
mind-bending first of its kind nightclub
residency and a chance for scott to
sample some of his upcoming music
according to a press release okay so
it's not like caesar's palace no i've
never heard of zoo me neither so i
thought it was more of a traditional
like shania twain adele moment yeah i
guess you know you do a few shows at any
vegas
establishment and it's called vegas
residency yeah and i'm not particularly
like a travis scott fan or travis scott
hater because i think you know you could
argue back and forth about the
astroworld situation endlessly
i just as a person who watched the whole
thing unravel without any particular
like stake or stanhood in it i was just
like overwhelmingly disappointed in
travis scott's lack of energy towards
the whole thing um
and i get that he was probably you know
limited in what he could do or say based
on like the lawsuits but i was just like
really underwhelmed by him in general
yeah um
so i'm really surprised to see him like
moving forward so fast this isn't like a
scandal like where you just like take
some time off
something wrong on stage and you know
you're gonna you know take time off and
you know work on your mental health this
is like so historic and so
much bigger than anything i think any of
us have ever really um witnessed and i
don't know he kind of like did a
terrible job in
handling it yeah and it can't be an easy
thing to have handled and i'm sure it
you know like keeps him up at night but
i don't know i was just like
from him and like entirely i agree with
all of that and i'm mostly curious if
people are gonna go
right like where do people
i'm not like a huge fan of his music
like i'm sure i know a lot just because
it's popular but i don't seek out him on
spotify or like his concert so i'm
curious if people who did like were
their opinion of him has changed at all
i'm very curious too
and if you're a travis scott gurley um
let me know in the comments like if this
is he has like die hard fans i mean of
course and i think that's part of the
reason why
astroworld was so um mishandled was
because of the passion yeah there was so
much energy there because people love
him and you have to be able to
um handle all that and they were not
able to yeah but i also think i mean
it would be shocking if anything like
that ever happened
again in his realm ever again but then
the nightclub
has the power to let a certain people
amount let him out you know what i mean
it's not just a random cornfield in the
middle of nowhere right where there's
unlimited space right so if there's you
know capacity
plenty of room something like this
shouldn't happen yeah and as far as i
know he hasn't done performances um
since then other than like private gigs
not like open to the public buying
tickets type of event
so um the headline is a little
misleading to me i couldn't imagine
enjoying i know
after something like that yeah i do
think the headline is slightly
misleading um
because when you read it like obviously
what i pictured was like you know the
venetian or one of those major
this is a new type of so it's like less
it's less yeah and i'm sure like he's
gonna have to
humble himself right do things like this
that he probably wouldn't have even
considered and maybe he will gain enough
momentum and trust in people that he'll
get those bigger gigs again
it's just
it's weird yeah and i i don't think i
don't know what he should be doing you
know right i don't know what's know what
this has really never happened before
like what is the
the right way to handle it and i'm sure
that if in terms of like ticket sales
like if he wanted to headline a festival
like they
there would be enough people people
would come but i don't think any like
brand or any festival or any like
sponsors like really want to be attached
to his name for the foreseeable future
which i do think is understandable yeah
so far like he performed at 11 in miami
which is the same thing as this zouk you
know where they control the environment
environment and he played a coachella
party in a pre-oscar party so like
you've said private things
but agreed on the brand front and also
if there's anything that would have like
fellow performers right i can't imagine
everyone wanting to be like totally cool
with performing alongside him yeah
now it's interesting this is like a i
feel like this is uncharted territory
when it comes like celebrity um
i want to see scandal because i feel
like that diminishes it yeah but like
for lack of a better word scandal like i
don't i don't feel like
there's any precedent like you know you
can compare this to because it's
literally never happened before yeah
plus the lawsuits are still ongoing yeah
so it it also feels weird to be getting
back out there when it's not a closed
case
there's nearly 2 2 800 victims who are
suing for negligence against him in live
nation as they should yeah
um
i don't know this is a story but like
did you see all this nicki minaj drama
no
there were so many like little stories
today that were like i just wanted to
make like a section called like items
uh-huh but then i forgot so this woman
who was claiming to be nicki minaj's
former assistant
is going wild on her instagram stories i
guess she got fired um and she said it
was like for literally no reason so she
decided to blow up nicki minaj's spot
and so much so i think nikki actually
addressed her i think it's
proven documented that this woman did
work for nicki minaj um and she's just
going on like i think over 50 instagram
stories
just
putting nicki on blast with things um as
it pertains to her relationship with
other um artists with rihanna with jay-z
with drake with a little wayne um
alleging that there's a sex tape of
nicki minaj going around alleging that
rihanna doesn't [ __ ] with um
nicki minaj since 2016 alleging that she
kept saying ken who is nikki's husband
who we were just discussing is uh
a sex offender right yeah um
he apparently like keeps acting out
towards all these people severing
relationships between nikki and other
artists now i don't know if any of this
is valid or true um
but it was like a train wreck like you
could not look away
doesn't she have an nda so she addressed
that her nda um bars her from posting or
sharing publicly
videos or images like she she found a
skirt like a way around her her nda she
addressed it okay yeah it's very
interesting and again i don't like to
like talk about those things because
it could just be like some literal
random person in ohio just making [ __ ]
up um but i don't know i got the five
but like there was definitely some like
validity to the whole situation
okay yeah i didn't see it it didn't make
its way to reals yet no it did not
okay next story an update from yesterday
beyonce is removing the offensive lyrics
dubbed ableist from her album
renaissance
beyonce's team said in a statement to
variety the word not used intentionally
in a harmful way will be replaced
oh okay um that's not what i thought was
going to happen no and they really all
missed right drama that's what's
shocking here now that beyonce is
removing it but that like so it's not
like she was using it intentionally like
this was an unintentional mistake that
that was made which means literally
nobody on her producing team on her um
record label like nobody threw all the
people whose hands had to touch this
before it got to the final stage nobody
like remembered the thing that happened
with lizzo like a month ago
that's weird that's shocking to me
honestly yeah
yeah and they are gonna change it and
like take it down and i wonder what
they'll replace it with right i'm sure
it'll be like something similar to what
lizzo did like what did she wind up
replacing it with i don't remember
because i don't even remember the lyric
you know
i didn't i didn't listen to it and then
i didn't want to listen to the og one
and then like have to learn a new lyric
yeah um but it was like the same vein
like silly like i don't know
okay
we shall see we shall see it but i i do
find that shocking honestly yeah me too
because i would have thought she knew
that it was like a controversial word
and just continued on with it because it
became such a big thing with lizzo yeah
maybe she just really is like that
private you know like she didn't know
sure she is yeah but there are so many
people that are involved not one of them
caught the news that day not one of them
listened to the toes maybe you don't
like correct beyonce honestly like let's
say i was working as an engineer
i'm not going to be like does beyonce
know this is a bad word like obviously
she's [ __ ] beyonce she knows
everything you know that's i'm not going
to turn around and be like um miss
beyonce like i don't think that you
should use that word you know what i
also think it could be
it's like everyone was talking about
that there is this word that lizzo used
that's an ableist slur but no one like
you can't say it otherwise you'll
self-cancel so it's like what word are
we talking about right even if they did
listen to toast like i said yesterday so
many people were like what word are you
even talking about and for some people
like when i first heard this i was i had
no idea that they was remotely offensive
so
if we're not gonna say what the word is
maybe she missed it because nobody
actually said it and even when i was
reading an article yesterday and it was
s star star z
i was like shiz like
i didn't i still didn't know right right
right right you know yeah no that's an
extremely valid point
maybe she missed it because nobody said
it
no that's
logical queen like yeah
and maybe her team missed it because
they were like oh yeah lizzy got in
trouble for using a lyric we were
watching the toast and they never said
it no and like it couldn't possibly be
anything
that we are using because
facts like literally facts that's 100
what happened
yeah okay i'm still not going to say it
though of course not we value look we
just put up new wallpaper we don't have
time to cancel ourselves we're not going
anywhere
okay are you ready for our next story
only if it's a next story that's brought
to you by fashion pass oh the sponsors
today premium they start coming and they
don't stop coming we know so many
toasters already know about and love
fashion pass but it is truly the
stiniest clothing rental service you get
unlimited rentals for one flat price and
the best part about fashion pass in my
opinion is their clothing selections
it's everything of the store they have
the best brands like for love and lemons
free people show me your moomoo amanda
upperchar uh how do you say i'm a
richard or upper shard oh wow excuse me
french i say up richard but i say upper
shower obviously uncultured swine if you
hate spending 200 on one outfit that
you're gonna wear on vacation and then
never again um you should join the
trendsetter plan from fashion pass you
get to pick three clothing items and two
accessories for every order and you can
switch out your items as many times per
month as you'd like so you're not
limited to these five items for the
entire month you're done with them send
them back and get new stuff their
shipping is super fast they take care of
the dry cleaning and everything for you
so you literally just send it back in
the pre-labeled bag that they give you
when you're done then you just get to
choose new items it couldn't be easier
it's so simple and again i think what
really sets fashion pass apart it's like
actually cute clothes you know yeah and
also it doesn't need to be a big
occasion like right just you want like
for work i've been using fashion past
since 2019 it's the perfect
product for the toast because it's like
i want to wear something cute and fresh
every single day but like once you wear
once and especially like for everyone
like you wear it on instagram like it's
worn which is like so unfortunate but
fashion pass it's a solve like and it
doesn't have to be like a big thing or a
wedding but they also have stuff like
that but just like for a girls night i
want a fresh outfit and i'm not gonna
repeat it yeah um the favorite part one
of our favorite parts about it is that
if you love something and you want to
keep it totally fine you also get a huge
discount if you buy it from them
anywhere between 30 and 60 off it is a
way better option than constantly
shopping and it's so sustainable so we
actually have a special discount code
for you guys today if you go to
fashionpass.com
use code toast at checkout you will get
40 off your first month so you can try
it for 39. that's unlimited rentals for
just 39 with code toast fashionpass.com
i also happen to know a lot of the girls
who work at fashion pastor toasters so
you just know that the company is being
you know
um
incredibly toasty thank you with toasty
the company is being sustained by toasty
energy and you absolutely love to see
that we'd love to see toasters
supporting other toasters supporting the
toast it's a toast own business it's
toast on toast crime hara bursa
are you ready for our next story our
next two stories are actually some small
real housewives items that
felt big enough to discuss sure first is
kind of crazy yeah mcsweeney oh no no
that's second okay liam mcsweeney is
responding to a rumor she was fired from
real housewives ultimate girls trip over
a poop incident hmm
so what is it with the new york women
and taking dumps on television no not
even that but first of all liam
mcsweeney was sent home from real
housewives ultimate girls trip in
thailand interesting the rumor was that
she threw elephant poop at a castmate
and she was banned from thailand leah
commented on this post saying
she did not do that but she's
disappointed she hoped she didn't
disappoint any fans by not doing such an
iconic move she said i'm so she said i'm
so sad it didn't happen
but she was sent home
well what did she do and you
wait this is so crazy like i can't think
of a time in recent
history where someone has been
immediately
removed from a show like people get
fired at the end of seasons for things
they did on the show but like immediate
removal like not finishing filming i
don't think that's really ever happened
yeah i
i'm pretty sure like she's just
debunking the elephant poop partner not
the part that she was fired yeah i'm
pretty sure but that would be crazy if
the whole thing is a lie but i do feel
like that actually you know you know if
she's home and they're still there that
can be proven i feel like this is kind
of a testament to how far the franchise
has fallen like we're talking about
throwing elephant poop and i just want
to say like there's
it's probably not true but like rumors
start
from some somewhere and then they get
turned into like major like
fallacies but like
what whatever it is that happened like
poop had something to do with it like
people are just making [ __ ] up literally
um and this is just like this is so
housewives like it's so it's becoming
sorry like solo brow
and i couldn't even finish ultimate
girls trip because everyone was just so
drunk and nuts and like making no
[ __ ] sense and i don't know what this
like new era of housewives is that like
and i think it really started with
ultimate girls trip and i don't know if
people are liking it or if it's helping
the ratings or anything but like
personally it's not for me
it's not
for me this new one so this is ultimate
girls trip three in thailand with porsha
gizelle candice dillard heather gay
whitney rose alexia and marisol from
miami did we even talk about that this
is the crew no and honestly like that
sounds like a good crew except for
whitney and heather because i cannot
[ __ ] stand them in candace
have you no scruples
alexia and who was the other miami
aerosol like that's an iconic
foursome it really is
yeah and they're in thailand which is
you know pretty gorgeous and interesting
right i think that part of the reason
why i couldn't stomach finishing
ultimate girls trip was yes everyone was
chaotic everyone was drunk everyone was
messy but like they were also just like
in this house and also like the
berkshires and it being during this
house is like a character and i just
can't and it's not a level playing field
because she had like she was on some
high ground yeah you need to like that's
part of the story line is like this is
journey bow down to duration and i just
can't no
so um
that's interesting i hope this isn't i
mean obviously she said it's not true so
it's not true but like
if anything like this even remotely
happen that is so [ __ ] disgusting and
so far gone
from how to behave as a human being
right and at the end of the day it's
also far gone from like the founding
principles of the show which is supposed
to be like rich elegant women who would
literally never come close to a piece of
duty in their lives you know right
most people wouldn't no of course not
but like
and by the way that this honestly
the fact that it was someone from real
housewives of new york doesn't surprise
me because the real houses in new york
are particularly like disgusting in
their um like bodily excrements if
that's the right they're always talking
about like peeing their pants pooping
their pants ramona there was [ __ ] on the
floor when they were in colombia like
when they all got like montezuma's
revenge and they all had diarrhea like
they were talking about it like it's
really disgusting yeah and i'm not like
one of those people who's like above
poop
like i love a fart joke like i will
honestly like if somebody farts like
i'll never not laugh like it's funny um
but not in my housewives no and like we
i feel like we like talk about duties
sometimes but like there's no
duty anywhere
like we're not gonna like duty on the
toes you know what i mean like they're
talking about it and like showing it or
two different things talking about it
and like there being
a physical
element of it yeah is different yeah
yeah
okay great glad we cleared that up yeah
but i would like to know what got her
kicked off of a trip because a trip like
this it's like go wild yeah you know but
also how far is too far when i think of
these women in this group like they're
all extremely like
when i think of giselle when i think of
alexia like i don't i think of them as
like mature
porsche like
i don't see them as aerosol honestly
like i wouldn't put the poop thing past
the berkshires women because they're
like chaotic and so desperate for
attention because all of them have been
fired and all of them are dying to get
back on their franchise i could see that
happening but these women in bali like
where she got her own show like they
don't need to be like solo brow in order
and like cheap in order to get attention
yeah
yeah so
this is disgusting like really vile but
it didn't happen oh right right it did
not happen thank you reality check thank
you so that's good but like where the
[ __ ] did that come from ew and i do want
to know what actually happened like how
do you get kicked off of a of a trip
where you're supposed to go wild right
you know it's interesting mm-hmm
our fifth and final story a little more
real housewives news sorry guys but
taylor armstrong is joining the final
story i'm so sorry i'm so sorry is it
the taylor armstrong story that's
brought to you by manscaped per chance
yes it's the one ladies we all know it's
hot girl summer but what kind of summer
is your man having if your man isn't
participating in smooth sac summer then
what is he doing
that's right this is the summer to keep
his balls cool while still looking hot
with manscaped the leader in below the
belt grooming is making sure we have a
ball this summer by giving your pant
partners everything they need to stay
fresh dive head first into smooth sex
summer by going to manscaped.com and for
20 off plus free shipping use code toast
the manscape performance package 4.0
which ben actually does have has
everything you need to prepare that hot
summer bod whether you're gifting it to
your man or using it on your bikini
line let's keep your bush tamed with the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the package also
includes the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all your goodies
manscaped even threw in two free gifts
to their performance package 4.0 which
is the manscaped boxers and the shed
travel bag that will bring you come
will bring comfort to another level so
ben has never been one for like you know
having um like toiletries in like a
confined little package um or like a
travel
pouch and i'm very grateful to manscape
for all of their fabulous products but
mostly the shed travel bag like ben is
now a grown man who like has a nice
leather
looking pouch he throws in his trimmer
he throws in his deodorant like he's
grown up and that's all thanks to
manscaped you can get 20 off and free
shipping with codetoast.manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
codetoast.manscape.com
hot girls everywhere agree it is smooth
sack summer and get your man on board
before it ends great thank you manske
yeah welcome
what can i say except you're welcome i
have not stopped watching moana so
apologies
no that's good our fifth and final story
taylor armstrong is joining the real
housewives of orange county becoming the
first housewife to move franchises but
she's joining as a friend of so i don't
want anyone to get carried away but a
friend of is still like a stepped
launching pad it's a launching pad and
she's a friend of on a housewife on a
different franchise and that's new
and i'm wondering if she's joining us
tamara's friend of since they must
now from ultimate girls trip for sure by
the way i'm actually
happy when i think of like and i guess i
never really thought about how nobody
has ever been
transferred fired and then transferred
when i think of like who i would want
this to be i'm happy for taylor
armstrong like she's kind of um
she was like a sad sack and then her
life really turned around and i feel
like any time we ever either spoke about
her on the toaster she was brought up on
watch it happens live like from kyle we
were always getting really really happy
updates from her which made me happy
because i feel like she went through
like literally the worst
three years any human being could ever
go through like
raising a child with an abusive husband
you find out your abusive husband has
literally lost all your money and then
he commits suicide like it must have
been literally like the hardest thing
anyone on housewives has had to go
through and then every time we checked
in on her everyone said she was like so
happily married i know she was living in
colorado for a while so she's really
like a success story post housewives
that i was like happy for and i don't
know i kind of like love this and i've
been so
hard on oc housewives because like it's
terrible um
and i'm happy for taylor and i actually
think this is a good idea even though i
don't really see a world in which i tal
and like what is heather
doing like she was supposed to revive
the franchise and she did not
is she gonna continue because i don't
really see her and taylor armstrong like
getting along only noella and dr jen are
gone so that means shannon gina emily
heather
tamra
taylor
friend taylor
maybe other new people
i just don't understand if they were
going to let go of noella and dr jen
like why even
like why did they even bring them on
right and it's really not fair to only
give someone one season agreed eileen
davidson
right for example you might like them
more the next season but it's also like
not it's not fair to them because they
don't get to like find their feet and
get comfortable get comfortable and
perhaps do a better job but it's also
not fair to the viewers to make us like
give a [ __ ] about someone like force us
to watch their home scenes for like you
know a couple of months and then be like
okay and now you have to do it with
someone else never mind yeah
i don't know what is going on at the
real houses of orange county like
casting and i didn't finish the season
so i don't know what happened with
noella but like isn't she
incredibly interesting right divorce
puerto rico prenup no credit cards like
that was wild yeah just amazon happening
in real time
yeah yeah i don't know so like what was
the point of all this yeah
and is heather confirmed coming back and
you can only have so many false starts
like i feel like in the last few years
we had so many new people elizabeth lynn
vargas justice for elizabeth we
just as for her like we became invested
in her personal story she was [ __ ]
wild like she deserved more honestly
like i am an elizabeth lynn vargas stan
yeah no she could be brought back and so
it's been so many years of this where we
like get invested in someone and then
they're gone reset that i'm not
investing in orange county anymore
unfortunately yeah no i agree with you
that's a perfect way to phrase it like
so many every year it's like no this
we're cleaning the slate and of all the
times they've did that i did think this
most recent time was gonna be like the
time to do it and it didn't yeah
it just felt like in what world
would
heather be in the same room as noella
like it just it was so forced
and it just made no sense and i i love
this taylor thing i don't think it's
going to be the thing that saves the
franchise especially like she's not even
a full-time housewife yeah but it's
promising it's promising yeah no that's
a good idea
but again i feel so disconnected to so
much of the real housewives franchises
in like the last couple months like i
don't care yeah
and every time i see news about it like
tamara getting her orange back which i
actually thought was a good idea and
then like they made a whole thing on my
travis live about it i just like rolled
my eyes like
yeah and they should give vicky hers
back too i'm ready and i was someone
who's like vicky needs to go but we
spoke about this i do think she needed
to like be humbled be humbled realize
this is an ensemble cast
and i think now the show needs her and
she needs the show yeah
that's just my thoughts um
so ultimate girls trip is definitely
like making waves in the actual
franchise and i think that means like
the women who get cast on ultimate girls
trip who are like trying to get back on
their show or like get on a show in
another city like are going to go balls
to the wall because look what happened
to tamara look what happened to taylor i
wonder what this means for leah because
still new york up in the air especially
legacy i heard that they had casted
people
for the new generation yeah right didn't
you hear that i don't know did you know
anyone yeah do we know them yes oh cool
i told you like oh yes yes yes yes cool
i'm curious to see what happens with
legacy where leah lands i like her i
could go for her on either me too
but not if she threw out lip and poop
but she didn't well she didn't but she
didn't like what was the cause of that
what was the catalyst for that rumor i
don't know it had to be something like
bathroom related
whatever um those are the fastback
stories and you definitely didn't need
to know them you definitely did not but
that's the thing about the toast is like
we're gonna tell you what you need to
know but also what you don't need to
know no i don't know that judd family
drama you kind of need to know yeah
that's the lesson be nice to your
parents yeah just like keep an ear out
for an update on that yeah um and that's
our show tuesday came and went um so
thank you so much we hope you all
enjoyed our new stunning visual i know
that you did i enjoyed it just looking
at the monitor you looked like you were
gonna say something right i was gonna
say and i also hope you did take away
from this episode that you must go get a
mcdonald's chicken sandwich yeah and
while you're on your way there listen to
our new patreon episode um
don't forget patreon pre-sale for the
not like other girls final leg starts
tomorrow at girls no job.com
tour
and don't worry i'll be reminding you
about it all week on my instagram
podcast tick tock follow me and take
talk um and that's our show so thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i heart
rate of cast box all the places however
you listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an amazing
tuesday we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day
goodbye goodbye